[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you so much for coming.
I just really, first of
all, I want to express--
I'm going to read from
my novel which I just
finished two nights ago up
in my little office there,
a five year journey.
And, you know, I just
can't express the gratitude
I have to the
Radcliffe Institute
for having given
me this fellowship.
Especially the last couple
of years were very rocky.
A lot of things happened.
And there were some
terrible things
and some beautiful things,
like a baby being born.
But it was a lot
of interruptions.
So these last three months,
to be able to hole up there
and get this book together,
have been a godsend.
And, also, I just
have such gratitude
to the other fellows
at the institute.
Every single presentation I've
been to has been inspiring.
I've learned from it.
I've taken things from it.
In this book, you'll
see this narrator now
has a childhood memory
of feeding whole walnuts
to squirrels in Boston Common.
[LAUGHTER]
And then later on,
when he's trying
to imagine a meeting in a bar
between his mother and CIA
director Allen Dulles, Allen
Dulles actually says to her,
I hope you're enjoying
your time here in Boston.
And she says, the other
day in the Boston Common,
we were feeding
walnuts to squirrels.
And so it comes back.
[LAUGHTER]
This book, how do I
describe this book?
In some ways, it goes, you know,
Long Night of White Chickens
was a young man's book.
Now, not a young man looking
back on some of that stuff,
maybe it's sort of fictional
assessing of a life.
It takes place over
a five day period.
Actually, it's stretched
out on a seven day period
when a narrator,
who has had a life
in some ways similar
to mine, he's
come back from Mexico City.
He calls it for the
Lord Jim reasons I did.
He was living there.
But the repercussions
of a crime he'd
been involved investigating
created repercussions
for a lot of people,
not just him.
But he'd been warned that maybe
he should get out of there.
And so he moves back,
semi-reluctantly, to New York.
He's had a really rough six
years since a very bad breakup.
He's been utterly
alone for six years.
And he is now 49
and approaching 50.
And he's worried.
And he's sort of thinking
about these things.
He comes from a family-- and
this is a big part of the book.
During this trip, he goes home.
He visits his mother who's
now in a nursing home.
He has dinner the first night
with a girl who's contacted him
from his high school days.
He's going to end
up finally visiting
his sister, various people
who are important in his life.
So he's constantly
having those encounters.
But the way it's written, like,
his life is sort of constantly
churning through his head.
He's constantly having
to quote, throw,
you know, "what business
of I have in the woods
if I'm paying attention to
something outside of the woods,
to keep himself focused
on what he's doing.
He's constantly scolding
himself with that refrain.
And the big event
is that, like, when
he came back-- he's only been
back in New York a few months.
But suddenly, for the
first time in six years,
there are two women
kind of in his life.
And he's very excited
about that and wondering
what it's going to mean and
really obsessing on that.
I think it's relatable.
And you hear there's
some really rough part.
There's a really upsetting
thing I'm going to read.
He comes from a very rough--
you know, it's about, I think,
the long-lasting effects
of cruelty on people's lives.
Everyone in his house
certainly suffered a lot,
because of a very,
very violent father,
which you'll be hearing about.
And I think that his sexual
life at the age of 14
was very badly thwarted by
a terrible act of bullying
in junior high that you will--
you hear in the book.
I'm not going to
read about that,
but it's a big
event in the book.
And so it's about, you know,
the trouble with intimacy
and not being able--
six years, and he
hasn't been near anybody
though his life is functional
in every other way, you know?
So that's kind of
what this is about.
So I'm just going
to read a few parts.
And if I have to say something
to introduce them, I will.
"What I believe is that even a
seeming lifetime of loneliness
can end from one day to
the next, even from one
instant to the next.
You can never have loved
and never been loved,
or you can have loved and
never been loved back.
But either of those
conditions can
be reversed, become
truly loving and loved,
dismissing for the
moment questions
about what that actually means.
For the very first time
at 49, does anybody
believe in such a fairy tale?
Proust wrote in his novel that
a man through the second half
of his life might become
the reverse of who he
was in the first, the reverse.
I believe that, too.
I even carry around a
notebook specifically
to copy down ideas like that.
I have it right here.
Alain Poitaud at the age of 32
took only a few hours, perhaps
only a few minutes,
to stop being
the man he had been up to that
time and to become another.
That's Simenon from The Prison.
From a César Aira novel--
the phrase, the fantastic
potential for transformation
that everything has.
He's far from being the first
writer who's noticed that."
He's always, like,
checking his phone
to see if, like, a message from
one of these women in his life
has come in.
So, here, one comes in.
"Lulu hasn't written, but
Jocelyn Quinn, yay, has.
Lady Jo writes, hope
you're having a good trip.
Have you visited
your mother yet?
Don't forget to bring her
those cookies she likes.
I'd made a mean
joke the other day
that Jo hadn't thought
funny about it being
pointless to bring my mother
her usual gift of a tin
of French butter cookies,
because the next morning she
wouldn't remember
who'd brought it
or even that the pretty
Parisian tin on her sill
was full of those
cookies she loves.
Whatever my mother
remembered later,
Jocelyn admonished,
she'd feel pleasure
receiving a gift from
her son and, also,
when she bit into a cookie.
Anyway, she said, I had told her
my mother wasn't so far gone.
I seem to want to exaggerate
her condition, perhaps steeling
myself for when
her dementia really
would become that severe.
You should enjoy her
company and get as much
out of your conversations as you
can while it's still possible,
Lady Jo advised.
Give yourself a chance to
escape to the Isabella,
reads her text message.
And say hello to
Hercules for me.
The Pierra della
Francesca Hercules
at the Isabella Gardner
Art museum I know means.
It must suck to be a
therapist and suspect
that everybody looks for encoded
therapy in all your messages.
It would make me want
to be outrageously rude.
Jocelyn, however, is a genuinely
empathetic and thoughtful
adult, her values and politeness
so deeply ingrained that they
are the authentic her.
But waking up in her
four-posted antique bed
was like finding myself in a
Henry James story of old New
York, one of those singer
sergeant women from the penguin
book covers lying
naked beside me.
The pewter hued winter
light in the parlor
floor windows, her
long boom white body
with protruding hips and
carnation pink nipples,
dark brown hair, lustrous as
mink spread over the pillow--
it was the first wasp
woman I'd had sex
with since the 1980s, that Peace
Corps girl from Wisconsin who
used to write her motorcycle
down into Guatemala City
from Momostenango.
But I'd vowed, since
coming back to New York,
not to racialize my
relationships with women so
much, a ludicrously
optimistic vow considering
that I hadn't been
in any relationship
at all in the six
years since Gisella.
You're a long ago pre-Gisella
Latina, Asian, and [INAUDIBLE]
girlfriends and lovers, where'd
that all get you, Frankie G?
One thing's for sure.
Not one had a bed as
cozy as Jocelyn Quinn's.
She splurges on bed linens made
in Italy mostly, always freshly
ironed white sheets smelling
deliciously of detergent,
a touch of lavender, goose
down pillows and comforter.
Huddled in her bed
in the frigid air
of that under-heated
apartment, I felt baked
into a warm fluffy meringue.
There are Italian touches
all around her apartment's
otherwise New England colonial
inn-type furnishings down
to the pot holders.
Even the bathroom soap
dishes and shower tray
are by some Milan designer.
She used to have a boyfriend
who was a clinical psychiatry
professor at the University
of Bologna, lived with him
there for nearly two years.
And she keeps a doorstop
Piero della Francesca art
book on the floor by her bed.
Jocelyn couldn't believe
that, despite growing up
around Boston, I'd never
been to the Isabella Gardner.
I really should go
and see the Hercules,
demonstrate that I'm
thinking of her, that I
want to try to experience
beauty through her eyes
and share her enthusiasms.
Jocelyn's the one
I should commit to,
rather the one I should
commit to pursue,
since it's not like she's
asked me to commit to her.
She had an especially
cruel breakup
with her professor boyfriend.
Soon after pressuring
her into agreeing
to an open relationship,
he fell in love
with one of his own students,
a girl 25 years younger.
Back in New York, Jocelyn
ended up in a rebound affair
with a bang on a can cast
member who chased her hard,
though he was married
five years her junior
with a two-year-old daughter
he sometimes brought with him
in the afternoons.
They'd leave the girl to
watch her Little Mermaid
video in the basement den
for about the millionth time
while they fucked
upstairs in the bedroom.
She'd finally put
an end to that one.
Jocelyn owns the bottom
two floors, the parlor
and the basement with a garden
of a brownstone near Cobble
Hill's little park and
the Episcopalian church
where we met on Christmas Eve,
like in some cornball rom-com.
I rent a one bedroom
in Carroll Gardens.
It works out between us.
It's not far fetched that I
could find myself becoming
a dad in less than a year.
But that could happen
with Lulu Lopez, too.
Can Jocelyn and I cross the
multiple frontiers between us
and love each other?
Lady Jo, I've come
to understand,
considers me not white.
Lulu thinks of me as
white, an American gringo.
At first, she was bewildered
when I reacted indignantly
to that assertion.
But, now, she likes
to tease me about it.
[? Mary ?] [? Ann--" ?]
his high school friend--
"probably still
regards me as a Jew.
Jocelyn asked me if
I were ever to decide
to see a psychotherapist if it
would have to be a Latino one.
That was during that
long conversation
we had in a wine
bar when, after I'd
been telling her some of
the usual painful stories
about growing up in
my town, but trying
to be as funny about them
as I could, Jocelyn said,
but Paco, you really didn't
get that calling you monkey boy
was racist?
Oh, come on.
She exclaimed.
I said, sure.
I said, but what if I really
did look kind of like a monkey?
You know how teenagers are.
She gave me a sternly
skeptical look.
I said, seriously, Jocelyn.
I've given this a lot of
thought over the years.
And I've concluded that probably
nobody in my middle school
looked more like a
monkey than I did.
OK, she said.
You have curly hair.
Your ears are not
small, but I really
don't think you
look like a monkey.
I said, I greatly resent
that you consider curly hair
a simian feature.
That's a totally false
stereotype, Jocelyn.
When was the last time you
actually went to the zoo
and looked at the monkeys?
Anyway, you left out a certain
chimpanzee facial expression
that my adolescent
classmates considered,
I don't think wrongly, to
be characteristic of me.
I let my mouth hang
stupendously open.
Jocelyn brought the back
of her wrist to her mouth
as if to stifle giggles.
But no, I said, I'm not planning
on seeing a psychotherapist
anytime soon other than you,
of course, off the clock.
But what you're
asking, I went on,
is if you think only a
Latino could really get
where I'm coming from, right?
You're suggesting that
I could be fucked up
in ways that a so-called Latino
therapist might recognize,
but that someone
like you might miss?
Jocelyn, straightening
her stool said,
well, I was just thinking
of how you grew up
and where you spent most
of your life and college
and how your last
long relationship was
with a Mexican woman and
just certain other things
you've expressed.
I think you do identify
as a Latino, Francisco,
and that it's important to
you even if you do sometimes
display ambivalence.
I understand that, too.
It's your nature
to resist being put
into a box, though not always.
Sometimes those boxes provide
some security, am I right?
I sat there nodding.
And then I said, I guess so.
She lifted her arms around my
neck, leaned forward to kiss me
and said, plus,
you're the only man
who's ever hit on me in
church, and I let you.
Wait a sec, I said.
You think my hitting on you in
church was like a Latino thing?
[LAUGHTER]
What suddenly
popped into my mind
was that pair of
buff Mexican twerps
in the Night of the Iguana, who
danced bare chested around Ava
Gardner in her hotel
garden, lewdly shaking
the maracas at her until
she shoos them away
ordering them to go fetch
Richard Burton's luggage.
And, again, I found
myself contemplating
this mandatory New
York intelligentsia
insistence, a not-so-intelligent
intelligentsia insistence,
on racially or
ethnically categorizing
and label every damn
thing, every person,
every artistic or
intellectual or political
or any other kind of expression,
like putting a brand stamp,
a Chiquita banana
on every banana
so that even in the
roses, our painful memory
needs to be compressed
and segregated
to such an origin in order
to be coherently discussable
in the therapist couch.
I know how exasperating
these obsessions
can sound to people from
places where this pressure
to identify people and
everything else in this way
that I so fucking despise
doesn't really pertain.
I wasn't despising
it then, though,
in the wine bar with Lady Jo
before going back to her place.
Because, for once, it was
working to my advantage.
Well, I said, it didn't exactly
happened inside the church.
But it started there
when the mass ended
and I followed
you outside, sure,
lewdly shaking my maracas.
But I don't think I'd
need a Latina therapist
to help me understand
why I was hitting
on a beautiful woman
who was by herself
in an Episcopalian church on
Christmas Eve, I told her,
any more than I'd need a Jewish
one to analyze my fucked up
relationship with my father.
It was only seconds later, as I
stared down at the zinc bar top
while maybe Jocelyn
was considering
my words, that the realization
fell like a silent ax
clinging something open.
I looked up and said,
Jocelyn, in that town,
it was really the
mothers who were
the bigots more than the kids.
Their faces came back to me one
after the other, Ethel Brown
meanly regarding me from
out of her cold cream mask.
The Jewish neighborhood
mothers snubbed by mom
and were jealous of
and feared her beauty.
Mrs. [? Sacco-- ?]
the sultry ignorance
and that fish-eyed
stare of hers,
always going around in
summer with blouses knotted
to expose her midriff,
like she thought
she was Elly May Clampettoni.
And Mrs. Lucas-- straddling
the spine of her flying
copy of Portnoy's Complaint.
Really, it was the mothers.
Jo, I told her, my voice rising.
It was [? Ian ?] Brown's
mother, Ethel, who
gave me the name monkey boy.
Silently, I rebuked myself.
The mothers, but so what?
Come on, man.
Don't blame the mothers."
And a little bit about Lulu--
"that night of the snowstorm
a couple of weeks ago,
Lulu stayed over, though she
said her cousin would be angry.
Even before we
reached my apartment,
where she'd never
been before, on the
walk from the pizza
restaurant on Court Street--
she'd never been to
a pizza restaurant
either as opposed to an
ordinary pizza parlor.
I'd already fallen a
little in love with her.
Clinton Street and
the falling snow
looked like a long
straight logging
road through a
frozen forest, snow
piled branches, shadowy
white striped tree trunks,
snow-blanketed parked
cars and trash cans,
the occasional taxi rumbling
past like a Soviet tank.
Behind the trees, lamplight
filled brownstone windows
as if emanating
from trench pyres.
All this scene through
a gossamer street light
glare caused by snowflakes
splashing into hot watering
eyes, mine and surely Lulu's,
too, that quiet winter storm
with its comical intrusions--
a woman, her
Portuguese water dog
flopping along behind her
passing on cross-country skis,
which Lulu also had
never seen before.
The skier cheerfully
called out hello.
And Lulu's voice
chimed back, hola.
On one-way Clinton and the cross
streets in both directions,
men were riding bicycles,
some with bike lamps,
the clacking and clinking
of pedals and chains,
wheels softly hissing
through the snow, hoods up,
stocking caps pulled low over
dark eyes peering steadily
ahead, scarves tied over
faces, freezing cheeks exposed,
leather pizza satchels
balanced atop handlebars,
and other food
containers and bags
in the baskets, the delivery
men and boys of Brooklyn,
mostly Mexicanos,
surely some Chapinas,
Guanacos, Catrachos,
too, bringing
sustenance to the
people living in all
those warmly lit brownstones.
[SPEAKING SPANISH],,
Lulu exclaimed
as we stopped on a corner.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
flying through the snow.
[SPEAKING SPANISH], I asked?
She grinned up into my
face, cheeks gleaming.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Lifting her mittened hand and
dropping them to point ahead,
Lulu said, look how they
go in straight lines
over the snow, [SPANISH],,
bringing food like [SPANISH]..
Lulu, I love that,
[SPEAKING SPANISH],,
I said, and put my arms around
her waist, both of us laughing.
That was over a week ago now.
In a shared lexicon,
Mexicans are now [SPANISH],,
they're [SPANISH] and [SPANISH].
But Lulu hasn't phoned or sent
the message in three days.
Lady Jo didn't write
last night either,
but it's my turn to
answer her last message.
I should've at least
texted a sweet good night.
What am I doing?
Don't tell me it's all
going to crumble now.
No matter what
happens, I'll never
forget [SPEAKING SPANISH],,
the wild exuberance
of our lovemaking that
night, the most joyous
I've felt in years.
I'm willfully conscious
that I have no right
to put any demands
or any expectations,
certainly not yet, on a
woman so young as Lulu.
Let's see if I can keep my word.
It's as if I want to be tested.
Almost noon, South Station--
I'm looking up at the schedule
board for the train's track
number when my phone vibrates,
a text message from Lulu.
It's in English.
[? Tania ?] want
know--" oh, yeah.
Lulu works as a nanny.
[? "Tania ?] want know, are
more windows in world or more
children?
So cute.
I tell that my friend
know the answer.
More windows or more
children [SPANISH]..
I walk out onto
the long platform
with a bounce in my step.
[SPANISH] and now this?
Isn't Lulu a poet?
Lulu, Lulu is the one.
I don't care what anyone
else says about it.
An image of myself walking into
that purposely overheated day
room on my mother's
floor where I usually
find her sitting in her
wheelchair sometimes dozing
like a dormouse, this
superfluidly of ebullience,
I mean love, sprang from me
like silly spring over [SPANISH]
and the other dementia and
Alzheimer's sunk old folks,
perpetually dozing, hunched,
contorted in their wheelchairs,
faces pale as frozen pie crusts.
Are there more
windows than children
in the world, or more children?
As we pull out of the station
through a sunny concrete
ravine, this commuter train,
its grimy steel floor, patched
and scarred brown
leather seats, reminds me
of a troop carrier,
namely an East German IFA,
like the Sandinistas used.
I managed to hitch rides
in the back of a few,
sitting squeezed on a bench
between young soldiers
and their AKs, smell of
melon grease, overheated
bodies inside fatigues of heavy
green cloth, overripe sweat,
and always a slight but
pervasive odor of shit,
perhaps result of what
constant fear does
to churning adolescent
stomachs already infected
with jungle parasites.
But what business
have I in the woods
when I'm thinking of
something outside the woods?
My hands, fingers entwined,
dangle between my knees.
Sitting on a train as it
pulls out of a station
is a quiet rite, a moment
to sit and face the self,
but not too long a moment.
My hands resemble me
more than my face does.
I'm more recognizable
to myself in my hands.
Every day I look at my hands
much more than I do my face.
I unclasp my hands and
stare down at their backs,
at the mole in the
middle of the left one.
That young Sandinista
officer, [INAUDIBLE],,
was convinced it
was a stigmata scar
and wasn't sure my presence
presaged good or bad.
But that was ridiculous.
For this mole to be
credible as stigmata,
you had to imagine people
worshipping at Christ
dangling from the
cross by one arm.
But in my dyslexia, I've
always relied on this mole
to tell me which way is
left, where they're trapped
inside that instant of panic.
Turn left.
I only have to remember
to look for the mole
on the back of my hand.
These are the knuckles
that crashed into the side
of my father's head, the second
punch landing harder than
the first as he fell forward,
the appalling sensation of bone
and skin through hair, a
criminal punch in a way
the first wasn't.
I can never recall it without
feeling a lurch in my stomach.
[? Tania ?] is the
little girl Lulu Lopez au
pairs for, her parents
are a Mexican opera
singer and his wife,
a financial analyst.
In a town like ours,
there are easily
more windows than children.
The house on Wooded
Hollow Road, for example,
had, let's see, five downstairs
windows, seven upstairs,
plus the sliding glass
doors onto the porch.
The overwhelming numerical
advantage of windows
over children in
Boston, New York,
probably in any Western city,
any city in China or Japan,
too--
but what about Lagos?
What about Mexico City,
more children than windows?
Or might it be close to a tie?
Traditional Maya village houses
have one room with mud walls,
are built from mud packed
with grass and sticks,
might not even have one
window, just a door,
often a half dozen children
or more living inside.
All over the world, poor
people's residences,
throughout rural
and village Mexico,
the southern hemisphere,
are more or less like that.
In the Amazon, well,
in every jungle
the environment I've been to--
way more children than windows.
Every child represents infinite
windows, [SPANISH] Lulu.
So does love.
Questions open windows.
I thumb these words
into my phone, sit back.
Jesus fucking Christ, that
I just write that corniness?
Did I just tell Lulu
that I love her?
Before the train
reaches my stop,
I quickly type 80% of
the world's children
live in poverty, so more
children than windows.
They're really not sure.
Moments later I
thumb, miss you."
So this next section,
he's visited his mom
in the nursing home.
And that's been a very
long intense chapter.
And, now, he's going to have
lunch with [? Felly. ?] And
[? Felly ?] is a girl, who
you've encountered an earlier
version of her in Long
Night of White Chickens.
She was sent to
live with his family
by his grandmother in Guatemala
when she was 14, basically,
you know, so that she can
go to college and study
and begin to try to make
herself into a teacher,
as she eventually
did, the mother here.
The grandmother
in Guatemala, who
actually has more money
than the family up here,
always sends a girl to
help raise us and help
with the housework.
And this woman becomes like
a lifelong incredibly close
person to him, right?
So he's come to visit her now.
He's going to see her
now for the first time
in several years.
He's in a taxi.
"We turn into the expanse of
old Charles River wetlands
filled in to make way for the
industrial zone, high tech
and online media companies."
Oh, one other
thing-- and this town
has changed so much
since he was a boy there.
It used to be a kind of working
class Irish-Italian town.
And it's now become a very,
like a lot of the 128,
you know, suburban
towns around here.
The housing values have
just gone through the roof.
And it's really changed, right?
"High tech and online
media companies,
the distribution hub
warehouses of box stores
and online marketers--
the Boston television
studios of a national network
are located here now.
[? Felly ?] asked me to meet her
out there at a sandwich bakery
cafe instead of in the
square where Gino's, formerly
our town's best and almost only
place to eat, is long gone,
replaced now by
half a dozen family
healthy food options
plus Thai and Indian.
The place is nearly empty.
Separate or together, asked
the young counter woman?
I look over each of my
shoulders and back at her.
Together?
Oh my god, she exclaims,
clapping a hand over her mouth.
I could have sworn
you were with a woman.
She's college-aged,
lively Irish pug
face, hedge of
reddish curly hair
down the middle of her head
closely shaved at the sides.
I make a frightened expression.
She giggles.
Believe me, sir,
I'm not on drugs.
I know this sounds
weird, but the woman
I thought I saw
standing next to you
looked like the French
actress in that movie Amelie.
You know who I mean?
I've seen the posters, I say.
Well, I wouldn't complain.
Oh, no.
You're sure wouldn't,
she says carefully--
cheerfully, going to
pour my cup of coffee.
I sit by a window
with my coffee.
[? Felly ?] is, what, 62 now?
But it never matters
how much time
has passed since the last time.
I always quickly reconnect
with a teenaged girl living
in our basement
on Sacco Road who
used to drag me
in front of the TV
to dance to Shindig!
or American Bandstand.
Whenever I talk about
[? Felly ?] and the life
she's made with her husband
here, the respect I feel
makes me reluctant to
pronounce American dream
with overt irony.
But I do anyway, probably
because the only part
of anybody's life
that's a dream, not just
a hardworking immigrants,
happens when they're asleep.
[? Felly's ?] second
husband, Giorgio Montolivo
is Argentine, from an Italian
family that emigrated there
after World War II.
He is the head
mechanic at a garage
that specializes in
repairing imported luxury
cars in Brookline.
He and [? Felly ?] bought
a small house in our town
at one edge of the
wooded swamp that
is bordered on the opposite
side by where the Kirby rubber
factory used to be.
When [? Felly ?]
and Giorgio were
in the process of
closing on their house,
the neighbors circulated
and signed the petition
that they brought to
the realtor protesting
that the sale of the
house to Spanish people
would lower their
own property values
and demanding the
sale be rescinded.
But the Italian-American
realtor, a car buff and soccer
fan who hit it off with
Giorgio, took a stand.
Still, [? Felly ?] hasn't
spoken a word to those neighbors
from the day she moved in
until now, not one word.
Their two daughters, both
taller than her parents,
went to high school in her
town and to good colleges.
And afterward, Gina
married a young man
from a prosperous family that
owns several locally famous
Seafood restaurants.
And the other, Jenny, became
an investment banker married
to an investment banker.
They live in a house
on the North Shore.
They've given [? Felly ?] and
Giorgio four grandchildren.
My sister's relationship with
[? Felly ?] is a bit strained.
Once, when
[? Felly ?] told Lexi,
you and Frankie really had two
mothers when you were children,
she says that Lexi
answered, I have one mother.
Who was the other one?
Whenever we meet, [? Felly ?]
retells that anecdote
as if she's still hurt by it.
But I wonder if
Lexi was just being
literal and, generally,
didn't understand
what [? Felly ?] meant.
Through the window,
I see [? Felly ?]
drive into the parking lot
in her blood orange Jaguar,
a late '70s or '80s
model that Giorgio
rescued from scrap at his
garage and beautifully restored.
She crosses the
parking lot sprightly
as ever, pixie hairdo
dyed a dark reddish
hue, big sunglasses of a
coppery tint, sprightly as ever,
pixie hairdo dyed
a dark reddish hue,
big sunglasses of coppery
[INAUDIBLE] lipstick,
tight maroon corduroys, a
waist-length leopard skin
jacket.
Must be fake fur, but who knows?
When she comes in through
the front door and sees me,
she puts her hands
out by her sides
and sways her hips like
she's inviting me to dance
and exclaims, Frankie!
[? Felly ?] always
greets me like that.
Her caramel feature's are
a bit sharper, more drawn,
but she's the same.
She could easily pass
for a woman in her '40s.
When we go up to order,
the counterwoman's grin
is rakish as she says,
separate or together, sir?
She thinks [? Felly ?]
is my wife or partner.
I give a cartoonish
wink, answer together,
and order the meatloaf
sandwich special
and a bottle of Snapple.
[? Felly ?] has an apple spiced
muffin and chamomile tea.
Back at the table,
[? Felly ?] explains
that she wanted to
meet out here instead
of in the square, because
she's fed up with the way
even the young mothers
in our town stare at her.
The other day, she was in
Walgreens speaking in Spanish
on her cell phone.
And as she approached
the cash register line,
she was so provoked
by a women's stare
that she erupted, excuse
me, do you know me?
Have we met?
Then why are you
looking at me like that?
Does it bother you that
I'm speaking Spanish?
It's not illegal, right?
Because [? Felly ?]
laughs, I do, too.
I know Frankie, she goes on.
Every year, this town get
richer and the people get worse.
And she puts two
fingers under her nose
and lifts it, pulling
her lips up, too.
I don't doubt the truth of
that or that the town is
as white as ever.
But I also think that
those young mothers mostly
see other adults who resemble
themselves day after day
and never encounter anyone
who looks and dresses
like [? Felly, ?] driving around
in her magnificent old Jaguar.
She clearly isn't
somebody's nanny.
I've finished my
sandwich, but [? Felly ?]
has only eaten some pinched
morsels of her muffin.
I'm tempted to tell her
about my conversation
with my mother in Green
Meadows yesterday.
But, instead, I ask her what
my parents' marriage was
like back then during
those first years
when she was living with us.
Did they at least get
along a little better
back then than they did later?
You'd think I'm doing research
for The Newlywed Game special
50 year anniversary show.
I'm about to make that joke,
but [? Felly's ?] expression,
the way she takes off
her sunglasses, stops me.
And her amber eyes,
smallish rimmed in black,
are something both
unsettled and resolved
shifting from one to the
other inside of a second.
Her voice surging,
she says, oh Frankie,
what you and your
sister witnessed
in that house no child should
ever have to see and hear.
I know, Frankie.
Lexi was too little
to understand,
but it was terrible for you.
You were so frightened.
You were always crying.
I have no memory of what
she's talking about.
I remember standing on my green
sofa by the picture window
during that first
winter in our town
when I was recovering from
tuberculosis, to look out
at the other
neighborhood children who
came into our snowy yard in
their snow suits and hats
to look at me on the other
side of the glass pane.
I remember crows screaming
across the gray winter sky
like the flying monkeys
in The Wizard of Oz.
I remember how icicles dangled
from the eaves of the house
and over the doorstep,
silvery and transparent,
narrowing into long, sharp
points that might break off
and stab deep down
into your skull
as you stood there ringing
the doorbell desperate to come
in and pee.
But I have no memory of
what [? Felly ?] begins
to tell me about my parents.
Twice, your mother tried
to leave your father
in those days, she says.
Twice, she'd had her bags
packed waiting in the living
room ready to flee back to
Guatemala and to her parents'
house again.
Once, she packed for
my sister and me, too.
But if I understand
[? Felly ?] correctly,
the second time she was
going to flee without us.
Both times, Aunt
Millie, summoned
by my mother,
rushed to our house
to tell my mother that she
wouldn't allow her to abandon
her husband, wouldn't allow her
to destroy her brother's family
and ruin his life.
[? Felly ?] says, Mr.
Goldberg sat in his chair
doing this with his hands.
She puts out her
hands, wringing them.
But, oh, she says, Aunt Millie
scolded Mr. Goldberg, too.
She told him that
he had to change,
or he was going to lose
his wife and family.
[INAUDIBLE] Yoli was all packed
and ready to go to the airport,
but Aunt Millie
convinced her to stay.
Two times I saw that, Frankie.
Two times I saw her convince
your mother to stay.
At your father's funeral,
says [? Felly, ?] Aunt Millie
came from Florida in her
wheelchair, so old now.
And she apologized
to [INAUDIBLE] Yoli.
At the funeral, I heard
Millie say, I am sorry,
Yolanda, for how you
suffered with [? Burt ?] all
those years.
I feel responsible, because
I forced you to stay.
Aunt Millie felt responsible,
Frankie, says [? Felly. ?]
And she apologized
to your mother.
Your Tio [INAUDIBLE],, didn't
like to visit your mother here,
says [? Felly. ?] That's
why, when he came,
he would stay at the
Holiday Inn in Dedham.
Tio [INAUDIBLE] knows how
your father treated Yoli.
He always knew.
Because of that, he couldn't
stand to be with [? Burt. ?]
I didn't notice
that conversation
between Aunt Millie and my
mother at my father's funeral.
I wasn't aware of Tio
[INAUDIBLE] hostility
to my father when I was a boy.
I was deaf to the icy nuances
in the forest [INAUDIBLE]
with which Tio [INAUDIBLE]
spoke to my father.
My mother sobbing in bed
with her nightgown ripped off
her shoulder, her skin
scratched and bruised,
scratched marks that bled--
[? Felly ?] seems to
think I'd seen that, too,
and must remember it.
How could I not remember
bloody claw marks
on my mother's
soft bare shoulder?
My father,
[? Felly, ?] tells me,
sat on the edge of the
bed, face in his hands.
Then he got up
shouting at my mother
and went into the bathroom,
slamming the door.
That didn't happen just
once, Frankie, she says.
Maybe I saw it.
Or maybe, hearing the commotion,
I ran to the bedroom door.
But I don't remember any of it.
My mother would tell [? Felly ?]
to take me downstairs.
Mr. Goldberg was impotent,
says [? Felly. ?] When Mr.
Goldberg tried to make love
to [INAUDIBLE] Yoli, she says,
he couldn't.
Then he would be enraged.
And that's when
he would hit her.
Your mother told me
everything, Frankie.
Because, in those days,
she had no one else.
Her uncle, by whom she
met Rodolfo [? Springer ?]
[INAUDIBLE],, the Guatemalan
Army Colonel who eventually rose
to general, who she always
says was like a father to her,
told [? Felly ?] that she
should leave her house.
She had no obligation to
us or to anyone to endure
such ugliness and sadness.
Her powerful military
relatives said,
she was young and had to
look for her own happiness.
But I couldn't leave your
mother alone with your father,
she says, or abandon
you and Lexi.
I couldn't, Frankie.
[? Felly ?] tells me that Tio
[INAUDIBLE] wife, [INAUDIBLE],,
phoned from Guatemala
to thank her
for taking care of my mother
and of me and of Lexi.
Tio [INAUDIBLE] she was right
to thank [? Felly, ?] I think.
Because of [? Felly, ?]
I was happy,
shut away as much as was
possible in our own world
in the basement, out
playing down back,
walking with her to the town
square to buy penny candy,
sometimes even going into
Boston with her on her day
off to see a matinee movie and
eat spaghetti and meatballs
in the North End.
Was Lexi, because of
[? Felly, ?] happy,
happy enough, too?
I think she was.
I hope so.
As a small girl, though, Lexi
was my father's favorite.
But by her early
adolescence, my father
had turned on her, viciously
insulting and deriding her.
I used to find your
mother shaking, Frankie,
shaking like this.
And [? Felly ?] puts out her
hands and makes them shake.
He was brutal with her, Mr.
Goldberg, says [? Felly. ?] Oh,
she suffered, Frankie.
Your mother suffered.
And she couldn't
talk to her family.
You [SPANISH] was such
a strict Catholic.
You could never divorce.
You were supposed
to accept your fate.
And [INAUDIBLE] Yoli was
always telling her mother
that everything was fine,
so that she wouldn't worry.
I felt like I was
responsible for your mother,
says [? Felly. ?] I wasn't
afraid of your father.
God gave me strength
to stand up to him.
I would get between
them and say,
I'm going to tell them in
Guatemala what's happening.
And that would
scare Mr. Goldberg.
That's when he'd
turn and go away.
[INAUDIBLE] Yoli used to
call me her salvation.
[SPEAKING SPANISH], she'd say.
Her studies and then her
teaching, that saved her, too,
says [? Felly. ?] That
was your mother's escape."
The book ends in New
Bedford where I meet--
I won't get into
the whole story,
but I go there with
[? Aba ?] Rubinstein-Wong,
who's a lawyer for a war crimes
unit in the Justice Department.
She was adopted.
I'll just read just a teeny
bit, even I go to two minutes
over just to end
on a more up thing.
But it begins with
this little thing.
Because it's appropriate
to New Bedford.
"In this notebook
where I copy down
quotes regarding human
transformations that
can occur even from
one moment to the next,
I have one by Herman Melville.
It's from a letter he wrote
to Nathaniel Hawthorne.
Until I was 50, I had
no development at all.
From my 50th year,
I date my life.
Three weeks have
scarcely passed,
at any time between
then and now,
that I have not
unfolded within myself.
Actually, Melville wrote 25.
I wrote 50, because
why the fuck not?
Have a Hawthorne quote, too.
In Wakefield, the
magic of a single night
has wrought a similar
transformation.
Because in that brief
period, a great moral change
has been effected.
But this is a
secret from himself.
If he has changed, but in
a way secret from himself,
do others notice?
I was adopted as a baby, says
[? Aba. ?] I was around a year
old, but there's no way to
know my actual birth date.
It seems like I was born
up in the highlands,
somewhere almost
certainly in [INAUDIBLE]..
But-- she shrugs.
What year, I ask?
I just turned 30, so
you can do the math.
Yes, the massacres were
getting under way by then.
Well, you know the history.
I silently calculate,
definitely underway.
[? Aba ?] says,
somehow I ended up
alone in the hands of
soldiers and was turned over
to a state orphanage.
That's all I know.
Maybe someday, she
says, a DNA test
will show that one of
those skeletons being
exhumed from the mass graves
was my natural mother or father.
But whenever I travel through
the highlands down there,
Francisco, I'm always
terrified that at any moment
somebody is going
to say to me, you're
a walking picture
of [INAUDIBLE]..
Was she your mother--
or some name like that.
She explains that
she was adopted
by Clara Rubinstein,
a geology professor
at Michigan Tech in
the upper peninsula,
but was also adopted,
unofficially,
by her mother's
partner, Mary Wong.
The Guatemalans would permit a
gringa single mother to adopt,
but not a lesbian couple.
But when she managed to track
down her official adoption
records in Guatemala
City, she was
surprised to discover that a
social worker had written down
the Dr. Clara Rubinstein lived
with her close friend, Mary
Wong, an artist, who's going
to help raise the child.
Mary teaches in the tech art
department, says [? Aba. ?]
She started out teaching
sculpture and pottery.
But, now, she's all
about Earth art.
The [INAUDIBLE] is obviously
a great place for that.
Anyway, Ma Clara used to go
to Guatemala every few years
on short term contracts to
work for an American company
exploring for oil in the Patén.
Needless to say, Guatemala
wasn't such a festive place
in those days.
To celebrate the adoption's
official approval, which
came through just before
the Christmas holidays,
Clara and Mary went
to Tulum, Mexico.
That's why, says [? Aba, ?]
on my first US passport,
my name is [? Jaba ?]
Rubinstein-Wong from
the Yucatec Maya words
for happy new year.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] She even
writes it out in a cocktail
napkin for me.
Clara and Mary pronounced my
name [? Jaba, ?] she says.
And that was a cool enough
name until Jabba the Hutt
made his Star Wars debut.
So [? Jaba ?] got changed to
[? Aba. ?] In grad school,
she says, Clara at Berkeley,
Mary at San Francisco State,
her moms fell in
love to ABBA music,
dancing under disco balls."
I think I'll stop there.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]